der Bundestag debattiert nach der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
zur Aussprache zum Europäischen Rat
heute und morgen und der nächste der
hier das Wort ergreift ist Christian
Dörr der Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kollegen und
Kollegen Europa
bleibt geprägt durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
Verbrechen gegen die Bevölkerung die
täglichen Menschenrechtsverletzung das
bewusste und willkürliche Töten von
Zivilisten von Menschen Familien das
geht weiter dieser Tage der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine gehört
leider zum Alltag der Menschen in der
Ukraine doch er darf niemals etwas
Alltägliches werden meine Damen und
Herren die russische
die russische Strategie hat sich ja
dieser Tage geändert das wird deutlich
30% des Stromnetzes sind zerstört und
mittlerweile über 1.000 Orte ohne
Stromversorgung russland zeigt dass es
auf stumpfe Zerstörung aus ist die
Terrorisierung der Menschen in der
Ukraine ist das strategische Ziel Putins
und Harry
eigentlich wollte ich nicht auf diese
absurde Rede eingehen aber es ist
notwendig denn das was sie hier
betreiben ist täteropferumkehr es ist
übrigens die Empfehlung dass sich
Deutschland aus der westlichen
Staatengemeinschaft verabschiedet wie
absurd es ist nicht im nationalen
Interesse was sie hier sagen das was sie
sagen richtet sich auch gegen
Deutschland es ist absurd so etwas
hierzu überhaupt der Opalla der
Aggressor sitzt im Kreml sind ihre
Freundin Kreml die diese Menschen
angreifen und terrorisieren
und ich sage das deshalb weil sie von
aggressiver Sanktionspolitik gesprochen
haben aggressiver Sanktionspolitik ich
habe gerade von den Terroraktionen
Putins gegen Menschen der Ukraine
gesprochen Herr Kollege rupalla liebe
Kollegen der AFD hören sie auf so etwas
zu sagen ich will hier eines aussprechen
das was sie anempfehlen ist dass dieses
große Land das sich Deutschland aus dem
Westen verabschiedet das darf niemals
Politik in Deutschland sein gerade nach
den Erfahrungen des Zweiten Weltkrieges
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
denn das Ziel
das Ziel Putins ist es die Ukraine zu
zerstören damit es sich nicht mehr lohnt
über einen danach zu reden und Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bin Ihnen dankbar dass
sie genau über dieses danach gesprochen
haben das müssen wir bereits heute trotz
der schrecklichen Bilder tun wir müssen
über einen europäischen Marshallplan für
die Ukraine reden und ein erster ganz
wichtiger Schritt ist die
wiederaufbaukonferenz am 25.10 hier in
Berlin wir wollen die Ukraine beim
Wiederaufbau unterstützen das wollen wir
bereits heute in aller Klarheit sagen
genauso wie wir die Ukraine bei ihren
Weg nach Europa unterstützen liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen und ich will direkt
jetzt
natürlich auf die Auswirkungen auf
Deutschland auf die Menschen in
Deutschland und unsere Wirtschaft zu
sprechen kommen Deutschland Europa
befinden sich aktuell in einem
energiekrisenmodus deshalb ist es so
wichtig zu betonen dass die Bekämpfung
der Inflation und der hohen
Energiepreise natürlich für uns alle
höchste Priorität hat und wir wollen
vermeiden dass es zu strukturbrüchen
kommt wir müssen uns in Europa auf
unsere großen Stärken deshalb besinnen
unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke die
Solidarität und Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union und auf Demokratie
und Freiheit und Herr Kollege
Entschuldigung gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der afd-fraktion
ja
ich neige normalerweise nicht dazu aber
ich finde die dürfen sich auch
öffentlich lächerlich machen
Kollege bistron sie haben das Wort ja
vielen Dank Kollege dürr das ist ja auch
in so einer Ärztin ernsten Situationen
noch ihren Humor bewarnt das ist gut sie
haben ausgeführt dass der Aggressor in
Moskau sitzt das stimmt
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen
nicht Deutschland und wenn sie sagen wir
sind als ein Teil Westen sondern wir
dürfen uns davon nicht verabschieden das
ist auch richtig aber ein Teil des
Westens waren wir schon immer und es war
eine gute deutsche Außenpolitik übrigens
liberale und sozialdiberale Koalition
haben sie betrieben die auf Versöhnung
ausgerichtet war auf Diplomatie nicht
auf Eskalation und es waren liberale
Außenminister die sich für Dialog
eingesetzt haben und nichts anderes
fordern wir von der von der AFD
[Applaus]
und wir hatten hier diese Woche gerade
einer Expertenanhörung die uns bestätigt
haben dass die USA einen aggressiven
Wirtschaftskrieg betreiben die ziehen
gerade Schlüsselindustrien in die USA
ist es werden Firmen hier in Deutschland
machen wir gehen pleite andere Firmen
wandern in die USA ab also bitte öffnen
sie die Augen sehen Sie das ganz
deutlich dass ihr transatlantischer
Partner auf unsere Kosten Politik
betreibt und Wettbewerber vom Markt
verdrängt und Firmen zu sich nach Hause
holt und davor warnen wir sie das war
der der Schlüssel der der die
Kernaussage der Rede von unserem
Vorsitzenden also verkennen Sie das
bitte nicht
also ich will eins betont viel Dank Frau
Präsident wenn ich Antworten darf auf
diese Frage das ist nicht mein
transatlantischer Partner sondern seit
vielen Jahrzehnten unser
transatlantischer Partner die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika den
Frieden nach Deutschland gebracht haben
die den Frieden nach Deutschland
gebracht haben und der tiefere Sinn wenn
ich es so sagen nach Ihrer Frage und die
tiefere These lautet ja wie folgt und
deswegen bin ich dankbar dass wir das
hier einmal ansprechen dürfen die
tiefere these dahinter lautet ja man
dürfe nicht Waffen die von dir
Vorsitzender als hier gerade erklärt
sondern man müsste reden
niemand in der Ukraine niemand hier
kommt doch auf die Idee zu sagen wir
würden uns nicht bereits heute Nacht
wünschen dass Frieden in der Ukraine
herrschen und das ist genau das was ich
mit täteropfer Umkehr meine Herr Kollege
natürlich wollen wir Frieden so schnell
wie möglich dort sterben Menschen dort
sterben jeden Tag Kinder und Familien
liebe Kollegen Kollegen es ist doch
Wladimir Putin der nicht über Frieden
reden will sondern kampfdrohen nach Kiew
geschickt hat das ist doch die Wahrheit
liebe Kollegen Kolleg und das Recht der
Ukraine sich zu verteidigen ist
abzusprechen indem wir Waffenlieferung
einstellen das wäre die wahre uns
Menschlichkeit in diesem Konflikt vielen
Dank dass ich das an der Stelle war noch
einmal darstellen durfte ich will jetzt
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen auf die Europäische Union und
das was wir energiepolitisch
richtigerweise tun können und machen
sollten zu sprechen kommen und Herr
Kollege Merz sie haben ein wie ich finde
richtigen Punkt angesprochen den ja die
Bundesregierung die regierungstragenden
Fraktionen bereits im Abwehr für die
deutsche Wirtschaft für unser Land für
die privaten Haushalte mit verankert
haben nämlich ein belastungsmoratorium
es war auch ein wichtiger Wunsch meiner
Partei Herr Kollege Merz ich teile Ihre
Einschätzung dass das auf europäischer
Ebene auch der Fall sein sollte ich will
es mal etwas entschuldigen Sie die
Wortwahl über spitz sagen es gibt
Wahlkämpfe der CDU die nicht erfolgreich
waren oder nach einem CDU-Mitglieder auf
ihre Autos hinaufkleber gemacht meckert
nicht ich habe CDU gewählt ich will
Ihnen antworten bei der Europawahl
meckert nicht ich habe FDP gewählt ich
würde mir wünschen dass die
cdu-kommissionspräsidentin das was sie
hier richtigerweise vorschlagen und ich
hoffe sie haben ihre Nummer das was sie
hier richtigerweise vorschlagen auch zur
Politik der Europäischen Kommission
macht sie haben uns voll an ihrer Seite
das ist aber keine Frage die hier zu
entscheiden ist sondern die
cdu-kommissionspräsident sollte diesen
Weg gehen wenn wir das zusammen machen
können Herr Merz wäre ich sehr dankbar
und glücklich das wollte ich gesagt
haben zu diesem guten Vorschlag
und es ist aber richtig dass wir
gleichwohl auf europäischer Ebene
gemeinsame und konkrete Schritte gehen
beispielsweise der Vorschlag Verein
gemeinsam Gaseinkauf insbesondere für
die Füllung der gaspeicher was ja wieder
notwendig sein wird im kommenden Winter
für die Jahre 2023 und 24 ist es ein
richtiger Gedanke hier ein Mechanismus
zu finden die preisdynamiken im
europäischen Markt Gasmarkt zu
verringern denn insbesondere mit Blick
auf LNG ist die Dämpfung der Preise im
Großhandel durch neuer Referenzpunkte
extrem wichtig solche technischen Dinge
müssen auch europäischer Ebene geklärt
und gemacht werden daher ist es richtig
dass wir sowohl auf europäischer als
auch hier in Deutschland auf nationaler
Ebene jetzt Schritte einleiten auch zur
Ausweitung des Angebots und deswegen
habe ich es für richtig gehalten dass
der Bundeskanzler erklärt hat dass das
Bundeskabinett dass die Bundesregierung
den Deutschen Bundestag eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
über diesen Winter hinaus vorschlagen
wird allein das Kernkraftwerk
niedersächsischen Emsland wird in dieser
Zeit 6,8 Millionen Menschen mit Strom
versorgen gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
auch diese Strom- und Gaspreise kann
sich kein privater Haushalt kann sich
kein mittelständisches Unternehmen
leisten und deswegen werden wir im
Rahmen des abwehrschirms eine
gaspreisbremse und eine strompreisbremse
für Deutschland installieren meine Damen
und Herren die 200 Milliarden Euro die
dort an kreditermächtigung bereit werden
bereitgestellt werden sollen es ist ja
nicht das Ziel einfach nur Geld
auszugeben meine Damen und Herren
sondern die klare Aussage zu tätigen mit
diesen hohen Preisen wird niemand
alleingelassen in Deutschland als
Solidargemeinschaft werden wir das
gemeinsam stemmen sein ganz ganz
wichtiges Signal dieser Tage lieber
Kollegen Kollegen und wir haben weiteres
getan die entlastungspakete sind von
meiner Kollegin Hasselmann vorhin schon
angesprochen worden auch die Volumen der
entlastungspakete suchen ihresgleichen
wir werden beispielsweise im Rahmen des
inflationsausgleichs bereits für das
kommende Jahr auch steuerlich die
Menschen unter die Arme greifen denn die
hart arbeitende Mittel in Deutschland
die diesen Steuerstaat trägt die hat
genau das verdient liebe Kollegen
Kollegen und wir werden mit der
gaspreisbremse über Einmalzahlung im
Dezember und dann
Ellbogen beim Gaspreis im kommenden Jahr
für die Unternehmen aber auch für die
industriellen Verbraucher und
insbesondere für die privaten Haushalte
die richtigen Schritte machen aber ich
will zum Schluss frau Präsidentin sagen
ich habe das vorne in Bezug auf die
Ukraine bezogen aber das gilt auch für
Deutschland und Europa wir sollten mehr
als nur raus aus der Krise wir wollen
eben auch an morgen denken meine Damen
und Herren und ich will an der Stelle
sagen dass deutsche
energiegeschäftsmodell die niedrigen
Gaspreise und gleichzeitig hohe
Unternehmenssteuern das ist dieser Tag
in Gefahr weil eine Säule weggebrochen
ist und deswegen müssen wir uns auch
energiepolitisch international
diversifizieren beispielsweise immer
energiepartnerschaften mit Afrika auf
der europäischen Ebene wird gerade das
Thema synthetische Kraftstoffe
verhandelt wie wäre es denn wenn wir
gemeinsam mit Afrika es hinbekommen dass
wir Energie von dort bekommen in Zukunft
aber gleichzeitig dadurch eben auch
zusätzliche Entwicklungsarbeit dort
betreiben können liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und ein ganz wichtiger Punkt heute
bereits an morgen zu denken ist dass wir
die nächste Krise die unseren Wohlstand
in Deutschland bedroht bereits in den
Blick nehmen und das ist der heftige
Arbeitskräftemangel bereits der kostet
uns bereits Wohlstand und
Wirtschaftswachstum deswegen wird diese
Koalition eine fachkräfteeinwanderung
bereits in dieser Woche mit einem ersten
Schritt und kommende Schritte werden in
diesen Monaten folgen auf den Weg
bringen meine Damen und Herren gerade
die Einwanderung in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt den Fehler der alten
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung endlich
zur korrigieren das wird Wohlstand in
Deutschland in Zukunft sichern meine
Damen und Herren und macht unser Land
aus krisenfester auch das will ich
unterstrichen haben
und
deswegen sage ich zum Schluss ich bin
für alle Vorschläge die dieser Tage
gemacht werden weil es gibt nicht den
einen perfekten Vorschlag sehr sehr
dankbar und Herr Merz sie haben mir in
ihrer Rede gerade immer wieder angemahnt
dass man mehr machen müsste aber das
Geheimnis was sie stattdessen
vorschlagen würden sind sie aus meiner
Sicht schuldig geblieben und das ist
nicht leicht keine Frage aber ich will
einen Vorschlag von ihnen aufgreifen der
vergleichsweise der vergleichsweise
konkret war sie haben gesagt anstatt 300
Euro für jeden sie haben ja gerade im
Finanzausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages die 300 Euro für die
Rentnerinnen und rentnerbewusst
abgelehnt ich halte das für ein Fehler
aber das muss noch mal gesagt werden
aber ich will ihn ich will ihn eins
sagen der Vorschlag zu sagen stattdessen
1000 Euro für das untere Drittel klingt
zunächst gut aber was heißt das denn
konkret was heißt das für den
Arbeitnehmer und die Arbeitnehmerin die
genau einen Euro mehr verdient als das
untere Drittel die gingen komplett leer
aus und da bin ich beim Bundes Tesla wir
lassen in Deutschland niemanden alleine
ich bin dankbar für Vorschläge der
Opposition das ist auch ihre Aufgabe
aber Sie müssen so konkret sein dass man
sie auch in deutsche Politik umsetzen
kann herzlichen Dank
Christian der
fDP-Fraktionschef war das